on your seats ukraine isn't a member of
nato but foreign minister dimitro kuleba
was warmly welcomed as a partner in
brussels a partner in need of support he
was very clear about what that should be
it's weapons
weapons and weapons his message was
heard nato foreign ministers promising
increased military support to help
ukraine fight russian invading forces
citing suspected war crimes in towns
such as butcher as a game changer
with each day
more and more credible reports
of rape
killings
torture
are emerging
and for every butcher
there are many more towns russia has
occupied
and more towns it is still occupying
places where
we must assume russian soldiers are
committing more atrocities
right now
without giving details nato secretary
general made it clear that not only more
weapons will be sent to the ukrainian
army but more advanced arms too speak
about more weapons right does it mean in
quantity or are you talking about a
different kind of weapon more as we call
it in a more offensive weapon rest
assured allies are providing a wide
range of different weapon systems
both
soviet era systems but also modern
equipment
and i think that this distinction
between offensive and defensive is a bit
strange
because we speak about providing weapons
to a country which is defending itself
despite a shift in nato's military
support for ukraine stoltenberg
underlined the security of alliance
members as its most important
responsibility so sending troops or nato
warplanes to ukraine are out of the
question
kuleba's call for weapons has been
clearly heard here in brussels while
nato countries were reluctant to send
what were described as offensive weapons
to ukraine at the start of the war this
hesitation seems to have gone now but
the question is will these weapons
arrive in time to prevent many more
deaths in ukraine
thank you very much
kulaibad criticized nato countries for
their slow decision-making processes and
highlighted germany for not doing enough
yet either you help us now
and i'm speaking about days not weeks
or
your help will come too late
and
many people will die
many civilians will lose their homes
many villages will be destroyed
exactly because this help came too late
with a large russian offensive expected
in eastern and southern ukraine in the
coming weeks pressure will be felt in
nato capitals to act fast the question
will be how russia will respond as the
kremlin is confronted with more nato
firepower step faster al jazeera
brussels